The third coronavirus stimulus package has now
passed the House and Senate of the United States,
slightly different versions were passed,
meaning it will go back to the House for
expected signature tomorrow. But most notably, the
third coronavirus stimulus package passed the U.S.
Senate with zero Republican support. Not a single
Republican senator voted for getting money to
more than 80 percent of Americans and getting them
some stimulus during this once every hundred year
pandemic situation that we currently are
facing. Let's look at Senator Patrick Leahy
announcing the passage of the bill in the Senate
to Democratic applause and I would say Republicans
silence. It actually looks like Republican
absence altogether. Take a look at this. Oh, no.
Senator wishes change a vote, if not the year
or 50 days of 49 bill as amended is passed.
Now, there are many, many things to talk about
here, first of all, because the Senate passed
a different version than the House, like I said.
The bill now goes back to the House and the House
is expected to pass this tomorrow, Tuesday. Then
it will go to Joe Biden for signature. And then
soon we will see money start to go out.
Could be within a week, could be 10 days,
could be a little longer. Now, the bill is
one point nine dollars billion in total.
It includes fourteen hundred dollar stimulus
checks for those making up to seventy five
thousand dollars a year. It phases out to
zero at eighty thousand dollars a year, three
hundred dollars per week in enhanced unemployment
benefits through summer, a child tax allowance of
up to 3600 dollars for one year. That that's
actually really big. And that's something that
here is being done on a temporary basis. But
there are many Democrats who would like to see
the tax code benefit parents through making such
allowances permanent. And that's something that we
can talk about as well. The bill includes
three hundred and fifty billion dollars
for state coronavirus aid, 34 billion
dollars to expand Obamacare subsidies,
and 14 billion dollars for vaccine distribution.
Now, if you have kids, this is a big win for
you. You would still get the 14 hundred dollar
stimulus check for each child and for yourself.
Plus, the tax credit is going up to the
thirty six hundred or three thousand if
the child is six and older. And there is really a
lot here for families with kids. And yet the bill
passed 50 to 49. The reason it's 50 to 49 is one
Republican senator was missing because of a family
emergency. Had he been there, it would have been
a 50/50 tie and then Kamala Harris would have had
to come in and vote to break that tie. Kamala
Harris didn't need to come in to break the tie.
All 50 Democrats voted yes. All 49 Republicans
who voted voted no. And this gets into
discussions about the political process that went
into getting us to where we are today. There are
people rightly frustrated by the watering
down of this bill by Democrats, but there
are also people reacting to this stimulus saga by
saying Democrats and Republicans are the same and
they're equally worthless when it comes to getting
people money that they need. The first take seems
correct to me. The second take is invariably
wrong, unquestionably wrong. I share your
frustration and believe it's terrible that Biden
said this would happen right away, but it actually
will be close to April before people see money.
I understood two thousand dollars to mean two
thousand more dollars, not 4500 more, which
makes it two thousand total if you include
the 600 dollars that will have been six months
before by the time people actually start getting
the fourteen hundred. Yeah, I'm with you right
there. I hate that the 15 dollar minimum wage
was removed from the bill. I hate that the bill
further restricted thanks to Senate Democrats
who qualifies at all for the stimulus, reducing it
from one hundred thousand a year to 80000 a year.
This shows us some terrible realities
about the Democratic Party, including
that the most centrist of the Senate Democrats,
people like Joe Manchin and Jeanne Shaheen,
they are very soft Democrats. They're obviously
not progressives. And while they are Democrats,
they're not Republicans. They are
Democrats. They're very different
than what you and I might say is the type
of Democrat that we want to see in the U.S.
Senate. But it's important to remember for those
like there's people mad at the parliamentarian
because the parliamentarian said you can't
include the 15 dollar minimum wage in the bill,
but Kamala Harris could have done an override.
Remember that even if Kamala Harris overrules
the Senate parliamentarian and says we are
putting the 15 dollar minimum wage in the bill,
then you look at the mansion vote and likely
some others, and you don't even pass the bill
at all and no one gets money. So there is a huge
critique of the Democratic Party to be made here
and it should be made. And we've been making
it, which is that lots of these Democrats
aren't very progressive at all. At the
same time, the overruling on fifteen
dollars minimum wage just means it doesn't pass
at all. And I don't think that's good either.
Now, on the other hand, every Republican
senator voted for people to get
zero and look at what still Democrats were able
to get done. So this is the other perspective.
Republican Senator Ron Johnson for no reason other
than to try to delay the bill, although it failed.
Ask that the entire bill be read aloud.
Republicans have acted to get people
zero and to make it take as long as possible to
give them zero. And despite that, Democrats have
have been able to pass. And when the House
votes for the updated version of the bill,
they will pass a nearly two trillion dollar. That
puts thousands of dollars into the bank accounts
of the typical family of four between the stimulus
money and the child credit. It establishes the
country's first real child allowance. It's only
on a temporary basis for now, but there's the
possibility it could be made permanent, which it
should be. This is obviously nowhere close to what
the American people deserve, but it's important to
resist the urge to self righteously slam it all,
write it off and say Democrats
and Republicans are the same.
This is a major legislative accomplishment
and it's desperately needed by Joe Biden.
It's not what was promised and it took way too
long. And those are critiques that are fair.
So when we equate Republicans and Democrats here,
it's silly. Although there are many criticisms
to be made of Democrats, their positions
aren't even remotely comparable, though,
morally and legislatively to those of Republicans.
Now, if you were going to claim that this is
merely happening, Democrats vote yes, Republicans
vote no because Joe Biden is president. And
if things were reversed and it was a Republican
president, you would have the reverse situation.
The answer is obviously not. Democrats voted
for every coronavirus relief bill during the
Trump administration. Not a single Republican
voted for Joe Biden's covid relief bill. And
yet you still have Republicans lecturing
Democrats about the need for unity and
bipartisanship. And we're supposed to pretend
both parties are the same. So give me a come on,
guys. You've got to give me a break on that.
This is the most loser of loser politics.
But Republicans and Democrats are nowhere
near the same on this. Let's get this signed.
Let's get money to the people. Let's move on
to the 15 dollar minimum wage and health care
and vaccine distribution and starting
to open things up as cases and deaths
come down significantly more, hopefully
over the next two to three months
and all of the other things
that need our attention.